hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Doctor Who episode 2 video
I'll definitely say like watching these
two episodes together these first two
episodes probably my favorite Doctor Who
premiere ever if you were to try and
watch them apart or out of order I mean
they'd still be a lot of fun but just as
this really grand big two-parter it's
like a small movie I tried to account
for that in my video last week like you
know the first episode a lot of fun but
as pacing goes not the best episode but
when you consider that it's really meant
to be the first part of a two-part
episode it's fantastic a new round of
the giveaway starts now all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video so here we go
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet starting with top 5
moments is everybody ready to be a god
number 5 a long time ago with the TARDIS
far far away just just the greatest like
setup for a Star Wars joke ever there
were actually a couple big Star Wars
moments in this episode let me see you
with my own eyes but the moment I'm
talking about is Missy story at the
beginning of the episode how she sets it
off talking about a past version of the
doctor without a TARDIS and we see like
you know Tom Baker running through frame
the only reference I thought of when she
said robot assassins in Tom Baker were
the robots of death episode the very
first Tom Baker episode was called robot
so you can you could probably draw a
couple different references there the
whole point of the story was just to
explain how Missy and Korra escaped and
how Missy escaped at the end of series 8
just modified vortex manipulator and
even just the way they shot the opening
scene was beautiful just like with
upside-down Clara spinning around one of
the big strengths of BBC programming is
is that because they don't have billions
and billions of dollars to spend on huge
special effects it pushes them to make
the cinematography that much better so
regardless of what you think of this
story Doctor Who episodes always look
fantastic on to number four admit it
you've all had this exact nightmare in
all honesty this was actually my
favorite moment from the episode just
because it was so hilarious and such a
big WTF moment I mean it really is kind
of a nightmare to see the doctor in
Davros as chair the last chair on Skaro
which is also just another funny Dalek
joke I can definitely admit to never
thinking about Daleks having to sit down
I guess they wouldn't need chairs on
their planet anymore the joke about the
tea is just like the meta commentary
every Doctor Who writer has ever had
just like don't question it I'm the
doctor just accept it don't question the
logic I know a lot of you
we're getting sick of the idea of
timey-wimey that was like a big Matt
Smith phrase really like the first 15
minutes of this episode or probably like
one of the funniest Doctor Who episodes
ever taken as the whole episode it was a
great roller coaster but just like the
first 15 minutes which is perfect comedy
I think that's what sets Doctor Who
apart from a lot of other science
fiction I can't think of another science
fiction show that balances comedy and
drama so well on to number three though
PTSD flashback to asylum of the Daleks
in Dalek Oswin there were a lot of you
guys that really wanted Missy to be the
new companion after last week's episode
I'm curious how many of you still want
her to be the companion after what she
did to Clara in this episode put her in
the Dalek and then just casually try to
get the doctor to kill her how do you
say I love you in Dalek the montage of
her getting Clara despit outlines was
pretty hilarious too and it's actually
pretty interesting I don't think that I
knew before this the Daleks say
exterminate to recharge their weapons
they don't just say it to say it so
maybe that's a Moffat addition to the
Canon of Daleks now it's always fun to
see examples of Russell Davies and now
Steven Moffat try to explain classic
Doctor Who tropes using new plot twists
onto number two the doctor and Davros
have a heart-to-heart and Davros
actually looks like he was crying at one
point which I'm actually wondering if
it's even possible for him to cry we get
the nice Darth Vader moment let me see
you with my own eyes
one last time just laying it on super
thick he gets super maudlin there
weren't there were some really nice
moments even though he took it all back
I'm wondering if for a minute Davros was
actually genuine when he said that he's
happy that the doctor was able to save
his people because I do think that
Davros has a twisted version of love for
his children for the Daleks but not in
the same way that you or I would think
about love really every single moment
that the doctor and Davros had in this
episode is just an amazing line you
could pull just so many things out of
this we've exhausted every conventional
means of communication we've established
one thing you are not a good doctor and
of course on to my number one WTF moment
very obvious here Davros tries to invoke
the Gallifrey and prophecy about the
Time Lord Dalek hybrid he tries to
siphon regeneration energy into every
Dalek on Skaro now there's just so much
to unpack here there are a lot of
prophecies and Doctor Who usually when
they
they're addressed within each season or
within each doctor's run this to me
seemed kind of like a twist on the cult
of Skaro prophecy there was a hybrid
that showed up during that storyline but
it was a human Dalek hybrid this is
Dalek SEC you can actually go back and
watch this on Netflix one of the Tennant
episodes that went really deep into the
mythology I actually really liked
episodes that invoke things like this
just because it makes you think you're
like wait a minute
when did I hear this prophecy before
what does this mean about future
episodes the BBC would do well to make a
book called the big book of Gallifrey
and prophecies they also kind of still
need to make a physical version of the
time war book that we saw during Matt
Smith's run just a very beautiful
looking book to have on your shelf the
twist and it all is that the doctor knew
that the regeneration energy would
regenerate the decrepit Daleks down in
the sewer and they would be so pissed
that they would just take out of the
rest of the Daleks for them just the
idea that the Daleks would have the same
word for sewer as they word for
graveyard it's just so hilarious I
actually you know even as tired as the
Daleks seem as a monster that doctor who
keeps going back to I felt like this
episode did Daleks really really well
let me know in the comments though do
you think that Davros was honest when he
said that he was happy that the doctor
saved his people that he brought the
Time Lords back I actually think that he
was sometimes the most convincing lies
have a lot of truth in them I mean
obviously he was trying to set the
doctor up so that he would use his
regeneration energy to help them but I
don't think the Davros would have seen
quite as convincing had he not actually
had some of those emotions inside of him
we are each of us a hybrid that was
actually my favorite misalign the friend
inside the enemy the enemy inside the
friend the only thing I really consider
unforgivable in this episode we know
within the context the narrative is what
Missy did to Clara that's the moment
where you just see murder on the doctors
face as he talks to Missy and tells her
to get out if you ever thought that
Missy had a chance of being the new
companion I think it evaporated right
there and speaking of Missy
the big question is is what is the
clever idea that she has at the end as
the Daleks are getting ready to take her
it seems like whatever she's gonna do
she's gonna co-opt them in the way that
she co-opted the Cybermen during series
8 you know definitely not in the exact
same way I don't think that Steven
Moffat would do that but do you think
that Missy's plan will mirror the
prophecy of the Dalek Time Lord hybrid
do you think that'll tie back into that
just for reference as your theory
crafting though
she'll Gomez has said that she's happy
to continue playing the mistress or the
master however you want to think about
her fur forever like indefinitely so
whatever her plan is its ply not going
to involve changing her self or
regenerating into another form but
Moffat did write the line in when the
Daleks were capturing her you are a Time
Lord so the fact that she's a Time Lord
she has regeneration energy in the Time
Lords themselves probably important to
her plan the doctor even made it a point
to talk about how he hopes he never
finds Gallifrey in the episode so I'm
wondering if Gallifrey is gonna figure
into Missy's plan moving on to more
specific Easter eggs there were a couple
of cool things that I spotted in the
episode I'm sure you guys spotted a
whole bunch more so just start writing
them in the comments as I go through
these
when Davros asked the doctor are you
ready to be a god that was actually a
line right out of Genesis of the Daleks
just you know going back to Tom Baker
also a lot of Genesis of the Daleks in
episode 1 I think it was actually during
the planet of the Daleks episode when
one of the companions or someone
referred to Skaro not being very
hospitable place to people that were not
Daleks and that's just part of Davros
finding a chair like I hope you
appreciate this because I had to search
everywhere for this chair when Davros
asked the doctor a my good man that's
right out of series 8 just conveying the
idea that Davros and the doctor two
sides of the same coin and then the
doctors Sonic's sunglasses I know this
is going to be controversial like some
people are gonna hate the sunglasses
some people want Clara des step on them
between episodes there have been several
other versions of sonic screwdrivers
throughout the series
Captain Jack had his own sonic device
Sarah Jane had a different type of sonic
device I'm not a huge fan of the
sunglasses right now I'm curious to see
how long they last but I'll say that
when I was a child my mom went through
like four pairs of sunglasses in one
year just because she lost them she
stepped on them she dropped him in the
water
so sunglasses do not last long so if you
really hate the sunglasses I don't think
that they're gonna make it to the end of
series 9 because I didn't have time to
get a QA out last week I'm gonna name
the giveaway winner right now from that
Silver Wolf gamer you win a $20 Amazon
gift card be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact info and the same goes
for this week if I can't get a Q&A out
before episode 3 I'll just name the
giveaway winner whenever I post my
episode 3 video so taken together these
first two episodes my new favorite
Doctor Who premiere ever in case you
guys haven't seen it you can click here
for my episode 1 video and there's been
a bunch of game
Thrones rumors going around a bunch of
stuff happening the last couple days you
can click here to learn all about
resurrection in A Song of Ice and Fire
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow